[Musique]
raymond théodose bonjour bonjour
monsieur livory et bonjour aux auditeurs
de martinique la première alors vous
mener la liste de la dynamique que la
dynamique pilotine vous êtes le maire
sortant de rivière pilote vous est en
ballottage favorable vous arrivé en tête
du premier tour avec près de 33% des
suffrages exprimés soit environ 1300
voix comment vous avez analysé comment
vous analysé ce premier tour s'il veut
que j'étais infos météo particulièrement
difficiles d'autant plus que nous étions
à la proche d'une de grands événements
que nous allons nous allons voir c'était
ça la difficulté
donc mon à bryant s'est effectivement
l'électorat ne s'est pas mobilisé
suffisamment pour permettre
effectivement que ce scrutin soit soit
vraiment un scrutin vous réfutez
d'accord la pandémie à jouer où il la
pandémie a beaucoup joué
d'accord est ce que le fait de ne pas
être élu au premier tour en tant que
maire sortant est ce que ce n'est pas un
échec mais pas du tout de toute façon
j'ai proposé une méthode de travail à la
population de rivière pilote
et puis il y a une chose si je tiens à
le dire
ça a été une mandature extrêmement
difficile déjà la campagne de 2004 était
particulièrement difficile
je me suis retrouvé seul contre tous
donc il fallait quand même jeu que je
joue un petit peu des coudes et je
disais aussi que nous avons quand même
au sein de cette mandature
oui cet état de catastrophe naturelle
et en plus de ça j'ai constaté que à
parti ou du moment que l'on ne faisait
pas quelque chose pour
un ennemi c'est bien il se fâchait et
comme on ne peut pas tout faire tout de
suite donc si je crois qu'il faut quand
même que nous allions vers là qu'est ce
qui vous a manqué pour passer au premier
tour
qu'est ce qui vous a manqué je pense que
il y avait quand même beaucoup de
candidats beaucoup de candidats mais
coûte candidats du même cours du même
bord pratiquement du même beau et puis
je dis aussi que c'est parce que la
démocratie a été salie vraiment à arrive
tout le monde trouve être candidat donc
il ya eu beaucoup de candidats mais
c'est je pense que ce sont ces éléments
là qui ont fait qu'il n'y ait pas de ce
vote dont beaucoup de candidats les voix
se sont dispersés mais comme comme je
vous ai dit au point 8 ou deuxième tours
ou xto donc je crois que je suis à la
disposition de la population si elle
souhaite me renouveler le mandat
je vais continuer avec elle en tout état
de cause c'est toujours la population
qui décide alors vous avez obtenue pour
le deuxième tour le soutien du cap et de
rivière pilote et de son président
edouard marrant qui était lui aussi
candidat au premier tour c'est important
ce soutien c'est surtout important pour
rivière pilote qui est ça soutient le
candidat marrant je le connais depuis
bien longtemps
d'autant plus que nous avons eu bruit
dans le bain partie donc je pense que il
ay là pourquoi c'est important pour
rivière pilote ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que ça veut dire qu'il ya une unité
de famille que ça voulait dire j'ai put
invite peut aller de rassemblement il va
falloir que nous puissions nous
rassembler at il derrière moi j'étais
mis un joli écriviez pilotes c'était le
far tout le monde voulait être comme le
vélo mais maintenant on veut plus être
comme ça donc j'ai envie et c'est ce que
nous allons nous atteler à faire c'est
de rassembler là la population de
rivière tout autour de véritables
valeurs que chaque essai sas a sa propre
sa propre au pe opinion mais corruption
nous rassembler et puis ne pas ne pas
tomber dans des cocons d'un débat bille
sait moins c'est pas moi c'est où
donc si ça que nous allons veut donc je
pense que si cette sagesse du candidat
du cap et qui a fait qu'il a pas opter
qu'il a demandé sachant que les voix
n'appartiennent à personne
d'accord et donnelly de louis j -c que
lui aussi était candidat est-ce qu'il
vous soutiens vous discutez avec lui il
avait jeunes juste avec tout le monde je
pense que monsieur régis fera peut-être
savoir au moment opportun ce qu'il
décide de faire alors si vous être élu
quel sera votre premier chantier alors
déjà continuer ce que je commençais les
négos le plan local d'urbanisme le papy
et puis il ya une chose qui me qui me
tient aussi ici c'est vraiment
réconcilier parce que je disais aussi
que il y a avant qu vide il ya près d'un
mois après s'il y a passé de solidarité
c'est ça cette solidarité cette union se
vivre ensemble on va passer à côté parce
que le peuple va beaucoup souffrir
donc le champ qui sera véritablement un
accompagnement de la population une
écoute et puis faire en sorte que tout
le monde se retrouve autour de
véritables valeurs comme la solidarité
le courage la sérénité qu'il faut
ramener à riga bildt
raymond théodose je vous remercie